Please welcome to the stage,
the stars of the show.
Nick Frost.
Selena heating.
Yeah.
Florence Q jack loud in and WWE superstar page.
That's fine.
Hello.
Hello everyone.
Well,
thank you all for being here.
Um,
what start with,
can you mind doing a brief introduction?
Who you are,
who you play 'em where everyone recognizes you from.
Hello,
my name is Nick Frost and I play Ricky Knight.
Are we done?
Yeah.
You don't know where I'm from?
Google me
because yeah,
my name is Paige and this,
uh,
this movie's about my life and don't Google me.
I'm Florence Pew and I play her in life all the time.
Lina Hedy,
I play pages
and I'm Jack and I played Zac the brother who's also over there.
Ominously lit.
Genuinely.
So,
so page,
let's,
let's kick this off with you for,
for many of you that
come on Granddad.
Sure.
For many of you that don't know,
there was actually a TV documentary that was made out of your family that kind
of started a little bit of this a picture.
What's it like,
uh,
at this stage in your career?
Very early on,
young to have a TV documentary in a bio pic about you,
you know,
with the rock.
Well,
when it comes to the documentary,
I was very used to being in front of the camera cause you know,
my mom died love to do a documentary too growing up.
So me and Zach,
what kind of used to that kind of stuff,
we didn't realize that the documentary was going to be so successful.
So a at won awards and we were really happy about it.
But again,
you don't think anything of it after that until I'm,
Dwayne approached me one day and said like,
Hey,
we're going to make a movie on you.
And it's like so bizarre to me.
It's very surreal.
So,
um,
yeah,
it's,
and it's very strange to see a girl playing you two and,
and she just did such a fantastic job.
She made me look so much better than I actually am and I'm,
I'm just really thankful for the cost to there.
I've seen incredible.
Apart from nick.
She's kidding.
Just kidding.
No,
I'm kidding.
I didn't get to meet page,
uh,
until after the shooting.
So what was it like,
you know,
being able to,
uh,
to pick someone who's,
who's real,
who's alive,
who's still very much in kind of the early stage of the career,
um,
to build your own character.
That was you and not necessarily just an impersonation of page.
So many questions in that.
Yeah,
I didn't,
I didn't meet her.
You can,
sorry,
I have a slight cough.
I didn't meet her until about three weeks ago.
Um,
which I think now looking back on it,
I'm quite glad I didn't because I think I would have been studying you probably
a bit creepily.
Um,
but
at the time page was injured and she had a neck injury and couldn't fly over and
we started filming.
So,
um,
we were just in contact all the time.
A very odd playing,
someone that's,
uh,
not only alive but only a couple of years older than you.
And this only happened a couple of years ago.
So she doesn't need a memory refreshing.
She knows about it all.
So I suppose,
um,
you just have to kind of take that opportunity and hope that you're not going to
offend or most of the time you hope that you're going to do the story justice.
Um,
and,
and also I suppose make sure that I find some peace in that storyline that I
need to tell as well.
So you have to make some sort of amalgamation and then just fingers crossed
because she can rustle.
So you hope she doesn't find it offensive.
Sorry.
Yeah.
Along those same lines,
you were able to watch a lot of youtube and film because of so much her being on
stage or on TV.
How much did you prep and watch for that?
I mean,
that's the best thing about playing a famous wrestler is that every single fight
she's ever done is on there.
And even the documentary was just so,
um,
helpful to use because you can see what she was like when she was younger and,
and around her family and how they spoke.
Um,
and actually getting the accent down.
That was really handy to watch the documentary.
Jack,
you played the brother,
kind of a very,
very big part of this,
take a lot of the emotional toll through this.
Uh,
I'm curious about with you doing a big core of the wrestling,
how much training went into,
um,
how much of the stunts did you do to prepare for,
for such a physical role?
Um,
quite a lot.
I,
I was,
eh,
Zack is a big lot as we call them back home.
Um,
he's a unit,
like there's just a law of Zack and I really wasn't,
I was sort of wafer thin and kind of pathetic.
Looking on,
told that very quickly by our director to em.
I needed to sort of,
there was a lot of work to do to kind of do them justice and so then they are
sore.
Gave me six,
six weeks to do that.
And so I had to eat like four or five meals a day.
I was given a trainer,
a crossfit training,
which is mental.
And I did that twice a day sort of floor.
I'm,
so I'd get the,
if I remember the first day I did it actually.
Um,
I mean,
I barely did anything in the grand scheme of things,
but went home and I fell asleep at three o'clock in the afternoon and I'm
morning.
I was only 26 at the time.
So that's,
that's quite embarrassing.
But I did,
I ended up putting on to roughly two stone,
so I went from sort of 79 kilograms,
so about 90 kilograms and,
but that's still wasn't even anywhere near the size that Zach was.
He's just huge.
Um,
but eh,
and then we were lucky enough to go over to the NXT and Florida for a week,
a week and a half,
and do some training with some,
some guys that were like there,
there were only like 60,
75 years old.
Um,
and sort of all walked around with our hands behind our backs and it was all
disapproving looks and sort of very little information.
And,
um,
it was wonderful though.
There's,
there was,
it was just hilarious that you had all these professional wrestlers going
through all their moves so beautifully.
And then me and Florence pujas sort of huffing and puffing and eh,
but,
but in,
in a good way I think.
But,
but no,
it was,
it was very,
very difficult but very enjoyable to,
to try and get near the sort of size of Zach.
And it does even just aesthetically,
obviously it helps,
but it,
I loved the way it felt to sort of carry yourself being bigger than that.
I've always dreamed of being anywhere near that size and that it was a,
yeah.
My favorite thing,
one of my favorite things about playing them,
but the more,
the emotional storyline of it.
This is the,
this is,
I'm realizing as I'm speaking,
this is the first time I've spoken about this in front of the reels out.
So it's a little bit,
a little bit,
little bit weird,
but um,
Eh,
his,
his story is actually remarkable.
Yeah,
let's get into that.
I mean,
that's a big part of the movie is the emotional storyline of not being selected
and then new,
a new baby,
a lot going on there.
And you kind of carry the emotional rollercoaster of,
of the character throughout the movie.
Um,
how did you,
you know,
I guess prepare for that and cover that while also doing all the physicality of
the wrestling room?
M I d I think it's a really cool thing.
That's th th th that it's been explored and I think,
um,
he,
he's an incredibly honest human being and I think everybody's probably dealt
with to some extent in their life.
I dream that they had,
um,
and it may be not coming true.
And,
um,
I think we,
you know,
in this script,
I hope it sort of true enough to,
to,
to what actually happened,
but you know,
it hits that quite hard in,
in,
in the film.
Um,
and as an actor,
you know,
I've obviously all of us have experienced that where there's a brilliant scene
in it where he,
he brings up the,
the gay who auditioned them for the WWE basic to say,
give us another Gore.
And I mean,
I've definitely thought of doing that,
um,
after auditions that I've,
that I've gone horrendous,
horrendously m and s.
So it was quite cool to do,
really,
really was it made,
it made it really interesting.
I love that.
It's,
it's,
and well,
I'm glad it was because it,
um,
the,
I did it with a guy who was laying in the foot,
well of the car.
He's in that scene as this little Canadian book lying there,
like squeezed up like that with sites with giving me utterly nothing.
So am I to stick my finger in my eye and uh,
do all the fake crying.
Okay.
And Zach was on set with you a lot,
so you got to kind of work with him and meet him throughout the
Zach's Zach's in the film.
And so there's an even weirder moment where,
um,
Zach plays a drug dealer in the,
Eh,
and I grew up in a van and look at him and he said something to me.
So that was utterly bizarre and they really,
really weird.
But,
um,
he's,
I,
he's a remarkable human being.
And I went up to north shore.
I was given a chance to go up there and watch him run the WEA w which is their,
their company.
And for me it's better than the WWE.
Um,
I'm a massive fan of,
of amateur and Semipro sport.
I'm a big semipro football phone,
buck,
stop their soccer ball,
uh,
back in the UK.
And,
and,
and I,
I picked people who have that much passion and who do it for,
you know,
a 10th of the money even,
nor money,
I think is,
in my opinion,
way more impressive.
And I think what he's done,
and he's such an enormous part of his community,
I really take my hat off to,
on these amazing,
yeah.
And teaching a blind wrestlers big part of that too.
Like the movie.
Yeah.
And that,
that's a verbatim true story.
He,
he taught,
I blamed care.
Total wrestle.
Um,
you know,
I think when you think you've done,
you think you've done something well in life,
and then someone tells you that a human being taught a blanket,
her arrest,
or like,
you're really not trying that hard.
Uh,
nick,
I want to,
I want to touch on the father figure,
a Ricky who talks multiple times about being a violent crime offender,
of going to prison for violent crimes.
You've done a lot of comedy.
How did you take that character that has kind of a rough around the edges but
also is the cornerstone of the family and really doing what's best for them in
and bring your version?
Uh,
I dunno,
I mean I think I'm always keen to point out that,
you know,
comedy and drama and not mutually exclusive.
Do you know what I mean?
There's comedy in everything.
Even funerals,
you know,
that's,
I don't think you can just be funny and not feel the other emotions.
Uh,
the human may feel.
Um,
I think Ricky was a dream for me to play really.
Cause it's as an actor,
it's everything you really want to be.
You want someone who's a bit funny on his emotional and is a lunatic.
Uh,
he,
he was a treat.
And I kind of,
I mean me and Zack,
Zack and stuff today and getting to know page a little bit and see in the
documentary,
I mean there are a lot like my,
my own family,
you know,
my own brother was a lot like Zack.
He was a bit of a loony,
um,
with a,
with a good,
you know,
good heart,
good egg.
And,
um,
I think we've,
Ricky,
I like the fact that,
you know,
so often you see a character who's bad or who has made a mistake and there's not
much redemption.
And I like the fact that,
you know,
yes,
he did that and he was those things,
but he's also a passionate father and husband and I guess dynamite in the sac.
Um,
why are you not?
But he's a trip.
He's a dream to play for me personally.
Cause especially with Steven,
I'm the director,
you know,
he,
he was keen that,
you know,
I add a little something in and I didn't want to do an impression of Reiki.
I wanted to,
uh,
kind of,
an impression of,
of who he was as a man,
you know?
Yeah.
And so you bring up Steven and a lot of the dialogue,
I mean,
it's very quick,
very witty.
Uh,
how did you kind of embrace that and bring that into the piece?
It was,
there was so much back and forth.
We saw a couple of the jokes of Vin diesel joke and all these other pieces in
there that they throw in.
Uh,
yeah,
I mean it's quite limp on the page and the actors really bringing it to life.
I think.
Um,
uh,
I know,
you know,
Steven Robert,
great script and we had fun and we had the time to muck about and you know,
once you've kind of honored what has been written,
there was always time for a something looser or uh,
an improvisation or if one of us have a better idea or,
you know,
we were allowed a voice and that's always a plus.
I think we like it.
We will like each other.
And the crew was great and I think,
yeah,
some of us like each other.
Yeah.
And the crew was great.
And I think that for me personally,
that gives you an ease and the fact that you kind of trust people enough to put
a bit of yourself,
leave a bit of yourself out there,
you know?
I mean,
what bit is,
yeah,
oh,
sometimes it was just liquid,
but other times,
spirit and heart,
you know,
but a lot of liquid.
Yeah.
Just to say that Steven really transport,
he,
he took away from the documentary and put onto page really well,
I think that was something that stood out to me was watching the documentary and
falling in love with that family was exactly the same as the way that Stephen
had put it down.
And I think as a testament to say how,
how good he did with the script.
So we don't want to ask you,
you know,
we talked about bad characters.
You're pretty famous for playing a bad character on TV.
Uh,
what was it like kind of taking the TV a big hit and playing into a movie and a
mom and someone who's here,
uh,
and there's a character and kind of embracing her role?
Um,
I,
well I'm such a big fan of Julia.
I think she's an incredible woman and I watched a lot.
I watched the documentary and I watched,
um,
interviews that she did and she's had a really interesting,
sometimes tricky history and so she sought to sort of powerful,
resilient person.
And I,
like Nick said,
it's like you don't want to do like an impersonation you want to do,
uh,
you want to portray someone with respect and bring in who they are at the core.
And all these characters are such big,
a joyous,
honest people that fuck up and do really well and nothing's hidden.
Like everything's just out on the table,
which is why you can't not fall in love with them.
Um,
and I didn't want it.
Julie's beat me up
his bottom line.
And how much training did you to go through mean you definitely have scenes
of the movie where you're in the ring.
And did you do a lot of uh,
training for the,
for the wrestling part,
two of us together and we told,
wrestled it was good.
I was always,
I liked wrestling.
I was a keen wrestler,
keen amateur wrestler.
I wrestled men I in pubs and privately in my own home.
Um,
and I,
I,
I'd always loved Dressler's boots.
I was always fascinated.
I was always like,
oh my God,
their boots were amazing.
And then when we started to do the film,
they said,
so we're going to meet you all hadn't made wrestling boots.
I was like,
oh my God,
this is incredible.
But just to kind of get boots on and,
and have a wrestle and the ring was very hard and noisy and squeaky and it was
great.
Right.
We had fun.
Anyone?
Yeah,
no,
I loved it.
I was saying earlier,
I can recognize everyone by smell.
So paid.
When you saw the film,
you know,
you have this amazing cast.
Did you,
how did you feel that they depicted your family?
Yeah.
Oh,
they killed it.
And I'm not just saying that because I'm sent upstairs at home,
stayed with them,
um,
or it's about my story,
but they really did kill it,
kill it.
Because you know,
95% of the,
the movie was very true to story.
And,
and they didn't get to spend any time with us.
Like I told apart from,
you know,
Jack A.
Little bit with who is Aggie boy over there.
But um,
I just fought.
It was,
it was,
I cried my eyes out like the first time I watched it,
like I see I blob it ever.
I couldn't get through the whole movie because I was just crying because I was
like,
these guys are just like,
it's so perfectly done.
And,
and Steven did such a good job in the script enough with like,
so if,
I didn't know if you guys have seen it or not yet,
or you're about to see it,
but they say some pretty crude stuff,
riots and some crazy stuff.
That's just something familiar.
But as Steven said,
like only had to do is pretty much follow.
My parents went with a notepad and the s the script pretty much wrote itself and
people always think that it's not real,
but that's the Luci who they are.
And,
and these guys just absolutely killed it.
And the thing that broke my heart the most was the CN.
Jack did such a good job playing my brother.
And the wonderful part of Zach story is the fact that it kind of shows you that
you don't have to be a successful in the way,
it shouldn't be measured.
Your sorry.
Your level is success shouldn't be measured by how famous you are or how many
people you have on Instagram or how many cameras are in front of your face.
So how many people you're doing interviews in front of success is,
is reaching a goal that you set for yourself.
For VR.
For example,
Zach wanted a family and now he has two kids and Zach wanted to train disabled
children,
had a wrestle and now he has someone with Down's syndrome.
He wants to learn how to wrestle someone who was blind,
who wants to learn how to wrestle,
you know,
and uh,
also you want to be part of my dad's company,
which,
you know,
if you guys want,
she says,
my dad said they're available.
Um,
yes.
I feel like Jack just portrayed that in such a wonderful way and it just,
it just completely broke my heart,
especially that scene.
It was absolutely incredible.
I was like,
I wanted a coach.
I'd be like,
I'm so sorry dude.
But
yeah,
they just did such an incredible job and I'm sorry the answer was really long,
but,
um,
I loved it.
Another big theme in the movie is I think the Rock Center says a line,
but don't try to be the next me.
You'd be the first year.
How did you embrace that?
I mean,
when you came on stage,
uh,
being,
you know,
from,
from Norwich and with all the models and the different,
he says in the movie
kind of,
yeah.
It was a little bit different.
Yeah.
Well,
when I first came over here,
like,
uh,
I didn't know anything about makeup was wearing my brother's hand me downs and
and I didn't know how to brush my hair still don't,
and it was just,
it was very strange.
I was,
I was very insecure.
Like I was confident enough to know,
okay,
I'm going to be in the WWE and I'm,
I'm gonna fight till I make it.
But it's another story once you come over here to a different country.
It was a big culture shock and,
and it was just so different because the women were so beautiful.
The kind of ones that you see in slow motion with smoke machines and doves
flying behind them and they're just like,
ah.
And I'm just like,
Damn.
And then there's me and my frumpy jackets and baggy clothes and like smelled
probably really bad,
you know,
like they're just so beautiful.
And so I was really insecure.
Um,
but the one thing,
even though it was super learning,
I didn't have any friends when I first came over here.
I still don't,
but,
um,
the one,
I'm never,
the one thing that,
uh,
I did have with my family and they just made me feel like I was,
um,
very unique in that case.
I was there and,
uh,
someone told me before that being yourself is your superpower.
So,
um,
I kind of took that and was like,
I tried to be something I wasn't,
which is when I lightened my hair and took my piercings out and got Tan,
which is so strange for me.
Um,
but,
uh,
I kind of took that after a couple of months of being there and cry my eyes out.
I'm like embracing it and being like,
you know what?
Fuck you.
This is me.
That's just how it was.
And then,
uh,
it kind of ran with that and now we're here.
So there's a lot of about perseverance,
wanting to quit.
I think that's very relevant to,
for the acting world where it takes a lot to kind of get to that level success.
How did that storyline kind of play to you as,
as,
uh,
actors in your career?
Open ended for any of it.
Am I dye?
It obviously plays a massive part,
you know,
you're not saving lives doing this.
Um,
you know,
you're,
you have to enjoy it in my opinion.
You,
you're,
you're obliged to enjoy.
It's your responsibility to enjoy it.
And um,
it's remarkable.
How often am I,
I'm probably not speaking for just me either.
So it's remarkable how often it's not enjoyable when,
because it's so about you,
this profession,
it's so you,
it's not like what you do with,
you can't do your work and then stand back and people can look at your work.
It's,
it's you.
And,
um,
I totally took that for granted before I got into this and sort of it's gotten
easier and harder at the same team.
So it's exactly what these guys do.
You know,
what they do is the perfect combination of,
of sport and drama.
It really is.
I,
it honestly is the best night I've had when I went up there.
it's,
it's tremendous and it's full blooded as well.
You know,
a lot of people in our profession get like a lot of credit for being method or
going deep and all this clinic,
you know,
stuff that they like to say that makes them sound a lot sexier than they
actually are.
But like if you want to see going deep,
you go and watch going.
What's the wea w like the,
like their commitment in front of an audience is,
is extraordinary.
And also,
you know,
it to do what they do and not in front of an audience that's that much bigger
than the audience.
We have no,
like,
you know,
the WWE without you respect her in front of 20,000 people,
it's probably quite easy to get jacked up and get into it.
But to do it in front of,
um,
you know,
not a great deal amount of people is,
is even more impressive,
you know,
and it's kind of like doing a fringe or the Edinburgh festival when you do a
play and like a cafe,
like it's a lot harder.
It's a lot,
lot harder.
So like the respect level's huge for what they do.
All right.
Anybody else have any thoughts on that topic?
Yeah,
Jack competent covered it a perfect.
Um,
so what was it like having the Rock Dwayne Johnson involvement in this?
There's a lot of parallels to his family,
uh,
into your family.
How much of that having him being a producer on this,
um,
played into a little bit more of like the overall wrestling family kind of piece
of this picture?
Is that an open question?
Open ended question.
Oh,
I never met the rock until last week,
so I was really nervous.
I'd never,
I was a big fan of,
I was a fan of the rock for years and then I kept talking to the producer,
kind of saying,
hey,
is though the real cover then a thumb down or the road didn't ask about the,
I've seen how fuzzy and I just said keep dropping hints and stuff and you'd have
a go ahead and touch.
But,
so then I saw him like last week at Sundance and I was fairly nervous and um,
I practice three or four different versions of how I would meet him.
And then at the end when you're faced with such a colossus,
all that falls to the side and you're,
you're just left saying,
hey here.
And that was it.
That was kind of what I go out.
I didn't know what,
I mean,
he does good in the poster.
He wasn't therefore,
um,
did you,
did you send him your Jumanji audition tape?
No,
I keep mentioning Jumanji too a lot.
Hoping that some,
there'll be some kind of trickle down costing,
but I haven't heard,
I haven't checked today but I haven't heard whether or not I'm in this.
I think they're starting to fill up their roster of actors on a Danny Glover
recently got costs,
but I met him at Sundance briefing.
He didn't who I was when I was
leaving there and if we did it,
I went home and he went hi and like Whoa.
And I went up.
That was,
that was my extra,
in all seriousness though,
he did work.
Um,
sorry.
I'm,
I'm going to give him some good,
good things now.
Needs help.
He needs a bit of help.
Um,
uh,
Jack and I worked with him obviously on,
on our first day of shoot.
He did the scene where he shouted to us for 40 minutes.
Um,
and yeah,
it was,
it was fun.
He's really big.
He eats a lot and I keep on saying that he,
he looks really smooth cause he does look really smooth.
Um,
but no,
we had a great time and we were both just so amazed by how he,
but he basically went away and wrote that and then we exchange lines to figure
out what we were going to say.
And then he walked away and came back 20 minutes later and he knew this huge
monologue promo and he just basically barked at us.
It was amazing.
Um,
and then also towards the end,
I,
I did,
uh,
the pages fight in the staple center,
um,
after Monday night raw and he was very much involved with the wrestling.
So that was really lovely of him.
And uh,
yeah,
those were the times that we work together.
So I do want to open up to audience questions,
so if people want on up,
we have two mikes on both sides.
Um,
while people are lining up.
I have a fun question for you and I'm there.
If you were a,
this is more for the cast since pagers has already been picked.
If you were a WWE wrestler,
what would your stage name be and what would your,
what would your finishing move?
B
Lena has a really good one.
Cool.
Choo Choo.
Yeah,
but she comes on to Chile.
That's like a locomotive.
My uh,
my fuel is farts
and I just released one long deadly woe to
talk to anyone that's ever been done.
Oh actually yeah.
Um,
not a,
which is um,
uh,
she,
she's a hot,
I want it part of the heart foundation.
She had to fight on screen a lot and not know it as the fact that she was fine
but Vince point,
it was hilarious.
There's yet she had to do it for months so,
so like so,
but she was,
she's done in front of people just like,
and that was all she had to do.
Months.
She got paid to fought.
Who did they have like a thing in her trousers were smoke would come out cause
that's got green gas.
Cooling your dad and being like,
Dad,
I did it.
Yeah,
I'm playing the falter.
Thank God they're not making me queasy.
I knew your Mama like that one.
Anybody else have a wrestling name?
Yeah.
Um,
I,
I would be called rump steak and he wouldn't be so much as a wrestler.
I've thought he would just be around the ring.
It dressed in like a dress and grown it addressing going,
it's,
it comes
from my prison name.
If I went to prison,
I was told that I would be cooking known as sort of rump steak and sort of pass
their own.
And in a sort of two,
he cane away and I kind of think,
I kind of think rump state could fill that kind of spot in [inaudible] so he's
not featured,
he's just always there,
every single wrestling match and he just walks to vote in a,
in a dressing gown and he,
uh,
and it's just sort of when he's given the signal,
he just comes on and it's just there just to be used in any way.
Does he cook key stake?
No.
Well,
never do anything that sends you to prison.
Just having her that.
Yeah.
It sounds like you had something awfully traumatic happened to you and this is
something that your brain is invented to cover it.
Wrestling.
Uh,
uh,
alter ego reminds me of of the alter ego.
The I came up with in case I wasn't page and it was me and Renee young and we
said we were dressed in dressing gowns.
Sir.
I don't know,
I'm stealing your gimmick a little bit but we would be cool to sleep as and
we'll put you to sleep and then we'll give him a buns on the rest and be like,
you just got a case of the Melatonin
and then you'd be like,
are you ready for your wet dream?
And then wow,
well you could,
I'm not going to tell you about it,
but they didn't happen.
No of course is an sl,
but it's an idea.
Yeah.
But you can join it.
No anything.
I definitely think there's a gap and WWE,
I think there's a market for something a little bit more high bro.
Like that.
I don't know Nigga,
I think we filled enough to allow the question.
One person lined up to there is stage Coleen.
First off,
thanks for coming out guys.
We really appreciate it.
Um,
I'm someone who grew up kind of watching like the attitude area,
uh,
attitude era of WWE.
So there was a lot of cool crossover.
It's cool at the rock is in this.
Uh,
were there any other stars from WWE that were on set helping out that didn't
make it on camera?
Oh,
I,
I don't know that part.
I just know the ones that were on camera and the moves he gets in everything.
So of course he was on there.
They can Mike,
it shows you,
it shows you a bitch.
And um,
but we had that,
that was the one day.
So when we show at Monday night raw,
we were there and we were Kinda just milling about,
waiting for our opportunity to go on after the show was over.
So Steven was that,
she'd just go down the whole thing like,
hi,
anybody want to be in the film?
Please be in the film.
And so all these like room walked past
these massive wrestlers were just walking bow in their little speedos and,
and like just,
we were just hoping that there'd be doing a gag with me and the food and then
that was a good one there.
That was like me when I,
when I first got there I was just like,
everyone's like,
you shouldn't eat that much.
I'm like only wherever I want to and I'm just grabbing hot dogs,
burgers and everything.
All the goals written like salads.
Like,
yeah,
I'm just like,
no,
I like food.
That was perfect.
I love it.
Cool.
Well that was that.
Sorry there was that one question you guys came out.
I,
I'll keep asking that.
So
thank you.
Everyone feel
nope.
Oh yeah.
Oh I on.
Oh you don't use the bathroom.
Oh,
he's off to do a shit.
Well,
hello.
Hi.
Uh,
I had to think of a question really quick cause I didn't wanna miss this
opportunity.
You.
But,
um,
I'm Irish so I'm not from the U S I noticed there's like a different sense of
humor in the u s than there is in the UK and Ireland.
I think we kind of get each other more.
So how do you think American woody and says we'll take to the movie?
I think no fucking love it.
Yeah.
Oldest screen is you went to,
everyone's literally dying laughing and I love that.
All the crying,
you know,
we did have to,
so there couple of the lines.
So there's a really good line in it.
Dick me dead buried.
We pregnant and when we'd be filming,
Stevie would have to basically measure how many Dick me,
dad's,
each person could get.
So like if someone said the f word or if someone said Dick or it would be like a
tally.
So there'd only be a certain amount of Fox and decks and Willie's there,
I heard they had to change that just for American audiences because it was,
fuck me dead marines.
You're only allowed like to fuck me dead,
dead sparing me pregnant.
And the rug was even allowed to say it.
Oh,
a lot pallets.
Yeah,
of course.
Sorry you,
I'm sorry you asked now
what was the question?
Okay.
Sensibilities in comedy.
Oh,
internationally you can answer that one.
Let me answer to that.
Oh,
uh,
I look,
okay.
So I mean,
I think,
I think if you try and
dilute or try and try and second guess what an international audience who like
you,
I think you dilute what the thing that is that made people laugh.
Do you know what I mean?
So I think things I've made in the past immediately that have worked all over
the place.
You just do what makes your mates laugh really.
And I think I've found all over the world,
there is that gang of people that then feel like what you've made is speaking to
them a new directly,
you know?
Yeah.
And Our van,
sir.
Okay.
So I would love to,
to hear what,
you know,
your,
um,
last go home.
Little bit bold now I'm joking.
Oh,
whoa.
Oh No,
this is that.
So this is my brother.
I don't have a question.
In fact,
I just wanted to,
I talk to you jack.
That's the first time I've heard you say anything.
Um,
my sisters told me about all the interviews you've done,
but you know,
just stood there and you just made a six foot,
three 18 stone guy cry to make sure that everyone knew here.
How much I appreciate you playing my character.
I know it would have been no one else of Barbara played my character.
Thank you so much.
And thank you from what you then call it.
Why'd you just give it
moment?
Yeah.
Does going to do the same thing to you?
Well that's a nice place to end it.
I'd like to thank,
we would like to thank you all for up.
I just have a look at a clip.
There's another question.
That's a beautiful moment to end on.
So,
uh,
one more.
Jesus.
We found thousands of miles.
There's two people at Google wants to ask a question.
Ah,
three that'd be good.
Thank you guys do and thanks for coming.
Thank you.
I was going to quit
growing up here.
Did wrestling was very much a part of it.
How can the culture,
when I was a kid there was it breakfast cereals in the Saturday morning cartoons
and you know,
and uh,
I was just curious.
In the UK,
what does it like,
is it,
is wrestling similar?
Is it,
is it part of the popular culture in the same way it was here?
Do you he's our wrestling,
the American wrestling popular there.
Uh,
yeah,
American wrestling is very popular over the,
actually that's where we do two tours a year over there.
Um,
is,
is pretty successful and when we do go and uh,
yeah,
British wrestling was a huge thing and we had wall to sport growing up and stuff
like that and it was good.
Big Daddy.
Yeah.
Um,
so,
but ace is really grown in the last couple of years now.
Like it has just Indy federations everywhere.
I don't see JP debris if opened up a performance center and to UK over that now.
So,
um,
yeah,
it's just a alive over there as it is here.
We're just a very small country.
So,
uh,
obviously is not as many.
Yeah.
I used to watch wrestling on a Saturday morning.
It was on for like an hour in the mornings and that was it,
you know,
and there was a,
as Paige said,
a character called big daddy and another guy called giant haystacks and they
will always,
they started off in their own,
they were a tag team and then essentially there became enemies.
So to watch those two guys going at it,
that was my,
my kind of beginning of wrestling and it was always,
I think maybe you know,
the birth of where w d a w started in small little halls around the country and
it would travel.
And the guy who presented it was a guy called Dicky Davis and he was very dapper
and he had like dense big black hair,
but he had like a white streak in it,
like the mum at the end of poltergeist.
Uh,
so that,
yeah,
that's where wrestling started for me as well.
You know,
in many ways I keep trying to think,
ah,
a biopic of their,
their battle would be a great film by keep,
it keeps getting knocked back.
People keep saying,
well it's two British perhaps and it wouldn't travel.
But I think that shit,
no,
we've opened up a gate.
Thanks for coming.
So to go on that question,
if you were a fan of wrestling growing up,
who was your favorite wrestler and why?
Um,
can I answer this question because I know I've always been a fan of wrestling,
obviously it's obvious.
Um,
but,
uh,
I really loved,
I don't know how big of restaurant signs you guys are in here,
but there's a woman called born Chicano and I was a really big fan of hers cause
she was very different.
She was this,
um,
really big Asian,
just beautiful woman.
And she was just so different to the rest of the women in WWE.
And that's where I stole one of my wrestling moves apart from Zach's Ba.
And then,
uh,
also I love Leah because she was very different.
And obviously Dwayne,
I'll put you over if he's watching,
I don't know.
And uh,
and stone called,
cause he just was just a Badass dude who was so amazing.
Yeah,
no one else like wrestling.
I think the stone cold was one of my favorites.
I know the old English bunch.
I,
I like big daddy and giant haystacks,
but when Kendo,
Nagasaki,
when he,
when he ran into the ring,
he was,
he was shrouded in like,
uh,
a Kendo mosque.
Uh,
he was kind of frightening and mysterious.
Thank you.
Hey guys,
thanks for coming.
Uh,
this question's for page one quick thing.
I did want to say that what you've done for women's wrestling,
it's been amazing
and I really appreciate it.
That being said,
where do you see it going from here?
Okay.
It's just going to keep getting bigger.
I think now we have a,
a WB evolution.
I mean,
I'm sad that I can't be a part of that,
um,
because of the injury that I had.
But you started it,
but I did start the damn thing.
So,
um,
no,
I,
I'm just,
I'm just really happy with where we're at,
where it's going.
We have so many amazing females now that's in the company and they're just
meaner than in all these big things like wrestlemania.
I never thought there was going to happen,
but hopefully it's happening this year and I just think it's just going to keep
just getting bigger.
They get w women in the doubletree and our unstoppable,
we're not looked at as a piss break or Elec tits and ass anymore.
We're looked at as,
uh,
truly,
serious in ruin competitors and uh,
no longer divas,
but we're superstars and I love that.
Thanks.
Thank you.
Thank you guys for coming.
I didn't know that was working.
Um,
this is probably mostly for page,
but it could be for everyone.
Uh,
you have a moment in the film or in the trailer when you're talking about,
hey,
you know,
don't be the first are don't be me be the first year.
Right.
So I'm wondering how people develop their persona is,
you know,
how does somebody become a hero or a villain?
And that might make more sense obviously in wrestling could also apply to
actors.
You know,
who gets cast as what,
how does that work?
Right?
So,
um,
when it comes to the WWE,
you have to,
you have to turn,
develop the character.
Doesn't matter.
Why is like,
like we had honed swell goal,
who is,
um,
who would dress like a leprechaun.
He was a,
it was a mirror image.
Yeah.
I don't know if that's the right time to say,
but,
um,
it just,
it's like WB can give you a character,
like they gave it to him or oh,
you know,
but with me,
I create my own character because I was just like the elevated version of
myself.
You know,
I just started screaming a law and,
and be an extra pale on knowing it and apparently it works.
Um,
but like with the process,
you have so much time in NXT that that you can develop a character,
like they have such a great,
um,
sent a down there where you have permanent clauses and you have teachers that
can work with you to try and try and help you create something.
And,
um,
but I,
I think the best way the character you can have is definitely just you with the
base turned up essentially.
So that personally for me,
what do you guys think about your wrestling career?
Okay,
wait,
what are you love it.
And as often got hornswoggled right?
That was his name.
Is there,
right?
It does ever people know who horns,
Walker was.
One posted anything.
Oh,
and the one in the back,
he was hornswoggled.
There was also another one called [inaudible] and he dressed like a little bowl.
We've had some characters.
I feel like we've entered another realm,
not the kind of realm you're thinking about.
Okay.
Amen.
Now,
the film was going to be in theaters everywhere on February 22nd.
So please go see it and you can find out more information,
uh,
fighting with my family.movie.
So thank you all for being here.
It's going to kill you.